the basic HTML for grabbing the canvas
object is pretty straightforward we've
seen this before the interesting thing
that we haven't yet covered is grabbing
the context of the canvas think of the
canvas object that we fetched from the
Dom as a Dom element while the context
is a handle to the drawing API s that
we'll be able to use to modify the
canvas visuals later in this simple
example we set the width and height to
1200 by 720 respectively now it's worth
pointing out that anytime the user would
resize the screen the canvas will remain
this size for the purposes of grits we
actually use the window inner width and
window inner height sizes for a canvas
allowing it to occupy the full screen
for the user